-Performing "Becky's So Hot,"
from her upcoming debut album,
"Girl of My Dreams,"
give it up for FLETCHER!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I wake up puttin' makeup
on a sad face ♪
♪ And Listerine ain't fixing
this bad taste in my mouth ♪
♪ Someone saw you out on Friday,
saw you walking sideways ♪
♪ Guess I'm getting touched
real good now ♪
♪ Fine, okay, I'll say ♪
♪ I went and stalked her ♪
♪ And I don't really blame you ♪
♪ 'Cause, damn, the waist
the hips, the face ♪
♪ This is awkward ♪
♪ Are you in love
like we were ♪
♪ If I were you,
I'd probably keep her ♪
♪ Makes me wanna hit her
when I see her ♪
♪ 'Cause Becky's so hot
in your vintage T-shirt ♪
♪ Ooh, she the one
I should hate ♪
♪ But I wanna know
how she taste ♪
♪ I kinda wanna hit her
when I see her ♪
♪ Becky's so hot
in your vintage T-shirt ♪
♪ I used to wear it, too,
yeah, it's the cropped one ♪
♪ With the red Corvette ♪
♪ Someone new riding shotgun ♪
♪ I can't even be that
mad about it ♪
♪ She flame emoji wow ♪
♪ It's always gonna
mess me up 'cause ♪
♪ Fine, okay, I'll say ♪
♪ I went and stalked her ♪
♪ And I don't really blame you ♪
♪ 'Cause, damn, the waist
the hips, the face ♪
♪ This is awkward ♪
♪ Are you in love
like we were ♪
♪ If I were you,
I'd probably keep her ♪
♪ Makes me wanna hit her
when I see her ♪
♪ 'Cause Becky's so hot
in your vintage T-shirt ♪
♪ Ooh, she the one
I should hate ♪
♪ But I wanna know
how she taste ♪
♪ I kinda wanna hit her
when I see her ♪
♪ Becky's so hot
in your vintage T-shirt ♪
♪♪
♪ Becky's so hot ♪
♪ Becky's so hot, no ♪
♪ And aren't you in love
like we were ♪
♪ And if I were you,
I'd probably keep her ♪
♪ 'Cause I wanna hit her
when I see her ♪
♪ 'Cause Becky's so hot
in your vintage T-shirt ♪
♪ Ooh, she the one
I should hate ♪
♪ Oh, she is the one ♪
♪ But I wanna know
how she taste ♪
♪ I kinda wanna hit her
when I see her ♪
♪ Becky's so hot ♪
♪ In your vintage T-shirt ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]